At sea, thousands of miles from any land,...
...the vastness of the ocean is giving way...
...to what some say is the largest garbage dump in the world.
Bottle caps, soap bottles, shards of plastic.
It's called the Great Pacific Garbage Patch.
It's mostly plastic which doesn't biodegrade.
It just crumbles down into smaller and smaller pieces.
The patch now spreads across millions of square miles in the Pacific ocean.
How far does it extend? It can't be too large.
As a matter of fact, it extends from just off the coast of California all the way to China.
It's bigger than the continental United States.
Charles Moore made the shocking discovery in 1997 by accident while sailing the Pacific.
He's been collecting samples of the growing Garbage Patch ever since.
Some samples contain six times more plastic than plankton.
It's been described almost like a trash soup.
It's like a minestrone that's out there...
...and all the little vegetables are different colored bits of plastic.
The Garbage Patch is caused by a series of currents in the Pacific ocean,...
...pooling what we all throw away.
The currents create a circular effect, pulling debris from North America,...
...Asia, and the Hawaiian Islands; and shooting it all into a graveyard of trash.
3.5 million tons of it.
80% is plastic and it doesn't decompose.
It stays as little plastic pieces for decades.